[Music]
so
[Music]
so
oh
on an empty street
[Music]
it
[Music]
i want it all
[Music]
[Music]
i
is
[Music]
[Music]
to do in one lifetime
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if
it now
[Music]
[Music]
wow
we have a city to burn world premiere
exclusive now comes the fun part
you and i
[Music]
[Music]
it up
[Music]
yes
at the end of the scene
hold up together
is
[Music]
[Music]
we can say
[Music]
will become
hey guys it's jeff keely and we are 10
minutes
away from the showcase event live
streaming around the world i'm so
excited to share this with you we will
see you in
10 minutes for today's live stream as
part of summer
game fest thanks for tuning in see you
in a few
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
did you like it
all around me are familiar faces
[Music]
myself
[Music]
it's
[Music]
foreign
went to school
[Music]
it's
[Music]
[Music]
dreams
[Music]
do
do
today we prepared an exciting
announcement for you
[Music]
all
exclusive did you like it
now comes the fun part
[Music]
we're living together
i guess
[Music]
it's the final downtown
downtown
[Music]
us
[Music]
the final countdown
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello i'm brian kerris technical
director of graphics here at epic games
hi i'm george of the special project
a few years ago we got together as a
team and brainstormed where we thought
we could push forward state of the art
and real-time graphics
there were two key areas that stood out
the first
dynamic global illumination beautiful
bounce lighting
instantaneously i don't have to be
constrained to do a game where the world
has to be static
and i'm able to iterate a lot faster and
we call this new system
lumen we're about to show you what it is
capable of
but first there was another area that we
thought we could push forward
truly virtualized geometry the artist
wouldn't have to be concerned over poly
counts
draw calls or memory you could directly
use
film quality assets and bring them
straight into the engine and that's a
big deal for artists
i just want to be able to import my
zbrush model my photogrammetry scan
my cat data without wasting any time
optimizing
creating leds or even lowering the
quality to make it hit frame rate
in the end that's what it's all about
art that just works
and we call this new technology nanite
here is the future of unreal engine
running live on a playstation 5. awesome
let's take a look at it
[Music]
this has to be
[Music]
before we continue let's stop a moment
and take a look at some of the key
features of this demo
much of what you see was built with
qixel mega scan assets
but instead of using the game versions
we used the cinematic versions which
would typically only be used in film
there are around a million triangles
each and thanks to virtual texturing
they all use 8k textures as well nanite
can render an insane number of triangles
very quickly there are over a billion
triangles of source geometry
in each frame that nanite crunches down
losslessly to around
20 million drawn triangles
what does that many triangles look like
this isn't noise
these are the triangles each a different
color most are so small that they look
like noise
nanite achieves detail down to the pixel
which means triangles are often the size
of pixels
this amount of geometric detail requires
shadows to be pixel accurate as well
and nanite can do that too speaking of
lighting
all of the lighting in this demo is
completely dynamic with the power of
lumen that even includes multi-bounce
global illumination
no light maps no baking here without gi
all of that beautiful lighting is gone
with lumen enabled we can move the light
and the bounce changes instantly
okay let's keep going
we've made some great additions to our
audio system as well
convolution reverb allows us to measure
reverberation characteristics of real
spaces
like actual caves that we sampled and
reproduce them in virtual spaces
sound field rendering allows us to
record and playback spatialized audio
all of this adds up to a more immersive
experience
this swarm of bats was created with a
niagara effect system
particles in niagara can now talk to one
another and understand their environment
like never before
we've also added a ton of new
functionality to run fluid simulations
like you see in the water below
the demo runs on our chaos physics
system here we are using it to
accurately simulate the rigid bodies
of the falling rocks and the cloth of
her scarf
now that the environment is so complex
we've needed to greatly improve our
animation systems to adapt
we've added predictive foot placement
and motion warping which dynamically
modifies ik
and body position to look more natural
for the character to more realistically
interact with the environment
we've added the ability to trigger
seamless contextual animation events
like her hand on the door promising
dynamic gi is amazing not just for
speeding up iteration
but also for its impact on gameplay
any light source can move while still
having beautiful bounce lighting
dynamic illumination means specular as
well which you can see on all the metal
surfaces
you can even see the niagara-powered
bugs reacting to the light
lumen not only reacts to moving light
sources but also changes in geometry
remember we mentioned high poly assets
this statue was imported directly from
zbrush
and has more than 33 million triangles
no baking of normal maps no authored
lods
and we can do more than a single statue
there are nearly
500 of that exact statue at the same
detail level placed in this room
for a total of over 16 billion triangles
from statues alone
[Music]
over this entire demo there are hundreds
of billions of triangles
[Applause]
[Music]
so with mana you have limitless geometry
and with lumen
you have fully dynamic lighting and
global illumination
all running on a playstation 5.
[Music]
there's not much time left and this
doesn't need to be constrained to small
rooms
it can stretch all the way to the
horizon
the portal is open
don't fail me now
ugh
it's time to see what's next
[Music]
there you go the unreal engine 5 is real
and
that was the first real-time footage of
uh something running on the playstation
5 as well such a
amazing day i think for gamers to get a
glimpse at uh where games are going next
and now it's my honor to be joined
by uh three guys from epic to talk a
little bit about uh today's announcement
of course we've got tim sweeney
kim library and nick penn warden uh guys
uh
thanks for joining me here virtually
this is uh a really
big and exciting day i mean i think i
just was so blown away when i saw this
footage about what uh ue5 can do and tim
uh
this is i know a special moment for you
to have you know put a five on this
unreal engine i remember
the first time you showed me the
original unreal engine i think it was
like 1996 at e3
um at uh marriott marina del rey and i
was looking back last night like the old
next generation magazine cover with like
can you believe this is what a pc
screenshot of the original unreal engine
how far we've come um tell me i mean you
know
this is a big moment for epic but um
what does this mean to sort of the
company right now to be able to you know
debut the first playstation 5 footage
but also you know introduce
you know a new numbered version of
unreal
well this really is a generational leap
or more and
technological capabilities and
the this the hardware that sony is a
launching is absolutely phenomenal
um not only an unprecedented amount of
graphics
power but also a completely new storage
architecture that blows a
buzz past architectures out of the water
and it's far ahead of the even the state
of the art and the
highest end pcs you can buy um and so
with unreal engine 5 we set out to build
a new generation of technology that
empowers creators to create
photorealistic scenes they're
indistinguishable from reality um
and to do so with a very high degree of
productivity
right i mean there are two problems in
game development right one
is uh the the features needed to
achieve complete realism um but the
other big problem is the
just the cost and time it takes for an
artist to create a major new piece of
content
for a next generation game and so under
launch and five attacks both of those
problems
we have the nanite system for virtual
geometry enabling
subpixel geometry uh which is
imperceptibly uh just impressively
different from the
you know full high quality assets so the
movie quality assets that were
originally scanned
also the lumen real-time global
illumination system
not only to bring unprecedented quality
and lighting to the environments but
also to free artists
from having to worry about the details
of
lighting their levels and make all these
set
trade-offs in static lighting versus
dynamic lighting and so
we're really trying to empower
developers here um and to
enable developers to create a new
generation of experiences that are both
unbelievably realistic but also
economical
and uh practical for them to create
without having to have a
a thousand person team yeah i mean when
you look at that footage
uh you know in 4k i mean just the level
of detail is absolutely stunning um
kim maybe you could break down a little
bit of this you know sort of visually
what's happening that makes it look
um so incredible because i know you've
got a couple of new systems that you're
really proud of
um and maybe talk about nanite and what
that is and how it works and how it's
gonna kind of shape games moving forward
okay so um nana is a new geometry system
for unreal engine
that lets us get down to almost sub
pixel levels of detail on the screen
you know it's cable but it's possible
because we have a new generation of
hardware
that really allows us to put loads and
loads of triangles at the screen
and we thought that we'd come up with a
new technique that
allowed us to be able to create content
in a similar way to the way that they do
on movies today
so in fact when you look at that demo
all their assets nana is basically
ingesting
all the movie quality assets from
quicksole to make that scene
and the artist doesn't even have to
think about it they can move rocks and
uh mountains and statues wherever they
want in the scene and not have to
worry about triangle costs anymore
lumen the global illumination system
that tim mentioned um
that just produces incredibly realistic
and accurate bounce lighting so
wherever you place a light in the scene
its effect on the whole world is seen
instantly by just moving things around
it's amazing
yeah when i saw that demo i was just so
blown away by the
the visual fidelity and also i think how
much
felt at least to me as an end user how
much felt
so much of the environment was streaming
in real time and so much detail
especially that sequence where she's
flying through the environment
um you know mark cerny has talked a lot
about playstation 5 and the you know the
incredible you know bandwidth it's going
to have to you know move data from the
ssd
you know right onto screen um nick can
you maybe talk a bit about how that's
sort of manifesting itself in this demo
i assume some of you know those
improvements in ps5 are
enabling types of things that just
weren't possible in previous generations
yeah um so nanite enabled the artist to
build a scene with um geometric
complexity that
would have been impossible before um
there are tens of billions of triangles
in that scene
and we simply couldn't have them all in
memory at once and so
what we end up needing to do is
streaming in triangles
as the camera is moving throughout the
environment um
and the i o capabilities of playstation
5
are one of the key hardware features
that enable us to achieve that uh that
level of realism
yeah no it's it's stunning to see that
and i think also you know
the global illumination i think people
have you know heard that concept before
um but now you know really manifesting
sort of in real time in that
environment with you know the flashlight
or some of the other you know lighting
scenes
can you guys maybe break down sort of
you know on the from the gamer
perspective like how games are going to
change because of the
the full global illumination well you
know
first of all this enables a much wider
variety of games um
to have uh very realistic responses to
light
um you know everything from uh
you know from large scale open world
types of games
um you know with day night cycles um
making seamless transitions from indoor
to outdoor
it's a just uh it makes lighting one of
the things that the developers don't
have to worry about
and uh you know it's a it's a freeing
technology um not only does it mean
more real-time lighting and gains but it
also means there's a large set of
problems that were
very tricky on the previous generation
that developers just don't need to worry
about and so i think you're going to see
a much
wider variety of types of games
taking advantage of lumen and taking
advantage of nanite and
one of the one of the core elements of
every new generation transition is
new hardware capabilities with an order
of magnitude improvement over previous
generations enable entirely new types of
games to develop
the battle royale john didn't even take
off until
the current generation where he finally
had enough computing and graphics power
to enable
a hundred player game um you know with
very very high fidelity encounters
um and uh this new generation of
technology that we're building with
unreal engine 5 and that sony's
empowering with playstation 5
will enable entirely new types of gaming
experiences that we can't even
anticipate yet
yeah there's been a lot of talk over the
you know past couple weeks about you
know the next generation kind of you
know
will the leap be as great as previous
generations what are the types of things
we're going to see i think this demo at
least to me
um you know is the first kind of
real-time example of of something that
uh really grabs me and i just want to
confirm like what we're seeing there
that's all
like you can actually play that with a
controller like that's not kind of
frame dumped or anything that's actually
playable it's a it's a fully playable
demo
and we plugged in a recorder into the
back of a playstation 5 dev kit
and recorded the signal that came out
over hdmi so it's a totally live demo
and it's replayable and it's a little
bit different every time you play it
wow no because i mean that that flight
sequence that's what's so exciting to me
is like this is you know real-time
um footage uh so what do you guys think
i mean when people say like you know
what is the leap of this generation
gonna be to sort of you know previous
generations from like playstation three
to four or whatnot
um is it is it any different this time
is it going to be greater less or we
don't know yet
i think the sense of immersion you know
one of the great things about playing
games is you
transport it to places that you could
never go in the normal world
uh this level of lying lighting and
detail really gets you to a point where
you're feeling like you're inside a
movie set that
things are so realistic and it's just
gonna it's gonna aid the storytelling
i think that the sense of immersion the
feeling of play i guess from actually
visiting a space
well i will be much deeper than you've
ever seen before
and the ability of the hardware and the
engine to stream in massive amounts of
content
as you're going through a huge
environment i think it's going to have a
much bigger impact on the on
on gaming than people are expecting
right now you know
until this next generation of hardware
um
previous generation console games had to
be built um to load data off of a
spinning mechanical device
right that has its roots in the 1950s
and now sony's storage system is
absolutely world class
not only the best in class and console
but also
the best on any platform better than
high-end pc i think
this is going to enable the types of
immersion that we
only could have dreamed of in the past
you know the world of loading screens is
over
and in the days of of you know pop-in
and geometry popping up as you're going
through these game environments
are ended and the resulting effect is
the ability to build games they're fully
immersive
from start to finish over uh you know
hundreds of hours of gameplay if that's
your game
yeah no uh incredible what i think this
is going to enable we've talked a lot
about ps5 we know obviously on real
engine runs kind of across
all platforms including you know mobile
and pc and xbox of course
um what's your take on like what you're
showing here how is that going to scale
to you know to other systems like this
demo we're seeing is that
you know will that run on the xbox
series x will it run on pc how will it
be different can you guys give us some
context on that
um well i mean unreal engine 5 is going
to run across
all of our supported platforms um next
generation console current generation
consoles as well as
uh mobile devices one of the
um one of the key features that we've
been working on
is being able to build content once and
deploy it across devices
um so on uh higher end hardware where we
can support
um nanite directly we'll be able to
render scenes of the fidelity that that
you just saw
like on playstation 5. um for say an
android or
ios mobile device what we will be able
to do is have tools that help to scale
that content down
so that you'll be able to take the game
that you built at the highest fidelity
level for console
and uh bring it to all other devices
tim do you have a sense between like
sort of all that you know like xbox
playstation all these other systems like
sort of you know they've made somewhat
different choices also
some similar ones obviously with ssds in
both do you have a sense of how they're
going to sort of compare in terms of
power or you know what how you look at
sort of like the the overall landscape
well you know we we love all of our
babies and we can't uh
make comparisons or pick favorites but
uh you know the ni technology we showed
here is going to run across all next
generation consoles um and high-end pc
um and most importantly
this is what's possible and the absolute
best hardware
that's going to exist um you know at the
end of the year but
these experiences you build we will help
developers scale down to
every device that exists in the world
and we we really hope and
hope to empower all developers to do
what we've done with fortnite in this
generation which is build
absolutely no no sacrifices high-end
console game
um and then bring it to every device
including scaling it down to ios and
android
devices from years ago so that
we can meet reach a much much much
larger audience of gamers than uh you
know just the
hardcore you know some 200 million
console players in the world
so kim i know a lot of gamers around the
world watch that footage and said
wow i i i want to play that but i'm sure
they're also trying to kind of
extrapolate out of that since it's you
know this is not a game it's a demo
um you know how their games are going to
feel
different in the next generation and one
of the things that i really took away
from it
um was that that flight sequence at the
end which was just incredible and with
you know the sort of the rubble coming
down and things moving
um could you maybe talk about sort of
how the game experience
might change with ue5 sure it's going to
look you know visually more beautiful
but how is it going to play different
so so traditionally on this current
generation if you wanted to make a photo
realistic environment
the way that people do that is they bake
lighting into the environment
the problem with that that means the
environment is not dynamic you can't
move things around
you can't incorporate user-generated
content because you don't know what it
is prior to shipping your game
but with this technology with the lumen
technology and nani it means that worlds
can be
super rich and super dynamic so just not
not just destructible components but
mutating components
and things that change beyond the
release of the game every day
an environment could have grown and
changed and that can all
be calculated live and does that extend
to like you know i
assume like destructible environments or
whatnot and allowing people to sort of
you know really like just
i mean i that sequence in the flight
where you sort of you know saw the
sort of tower crash down or whatever i
mean that felt to me
i mean i just hadn't seen that level of
detail in a game like that and some
games like uncharted or whatever
sometimes have big destruction moments
but it felt like that was
so detailed and so realistic is that
partially because you can now
move the environment more in real time
yes and even effects like when we open
that big dome where all the statues are
the light just floods in and bounces all
over the place you know you
you really the way you would have had to
do that in the past is you would have to
cheat
and now it can be fully dynamic you can
blow a hole in the sky
and the light will come through and you
know even choose randomly covered lights
if you put them into the scene as a
player
then they're going to have an effect on
the whole world and it'll still look
realistic
so in the past you could get that effect
but it would have to be sort of
pre-calculated i guess
is that how it worked yeah exactly and
even even if you wanna like if you're
saying you're in a dungeon and you place
a light
you see you've got a candle that you
happen to have in the game and you place
it
that will bounce around corners so you
can you can explore with limited light
sources and
the old-fashioned gag of having a
flashlight beam isn't what you need
anymore you can actually use light in
really interesting ways
yeah and you know even beyond games
unreal engine has been you know applied
to so many amazing uh you know aspects
of entertainment um of course you know i
think everyone knows the mandalorian how
that used unreal engine and you know
there's certainly
the weather channel there's so many
other uses of ue um
can you guys talk about how sort of ue5
is going to
you know kind of tie into those
experiences and i think you know
i assume you see this convergence of
kind of everything coming together
um through an engine like unreal in
terms of just realizing entertainment
um how will ue5 sort of you know be used
in those fields or how
how will that change the pipeline for
for non-game experiences too
so one of the great things about nanite
is that it
finally allows content creators of all
kinds to be able to use movie quality
assets so
there really won't be a difference if
you're building an environment for a
film
versus a video game or you're making an
ip that's transmedia you can build
things the same way now
and that was honestly that was you know
we had so much exposure to film
customers over the last few years
using our engine that we really wanted
to to remove the barrier
um for them and for all game makers
right now you just
you know you pick a high resolution
asset you want you load it in you don't
have to think about
making levels of detail or normal maps
or any of the usual stuff that goes with
making game content
it's a very freeing experience for
anybody trying to trying to tell a story
or to make an experience
that's amazing so you know in the eyes
of a consumer like you'll see an asset
that's in you know a movie and that they
literally can
drag that over to the game now whereas i
guess in the past they would have to
sort of you know reduce down the
polygons and kind of you know kind of
scale it down for a game engine
yeah and in fact actually quicksole um
that's also part of epic
their assets they come when you when you
take an asset from the qixel store
there is a movie quality version that
would be used in movies um
uh you know that i guess they were
involved a lot in the jungle book movie
a few years ago and many movies today
use quick slices
and they also have versions of them
assets that are suitable for games
now that you don't have to have that
distinction that knight will just take
the movie asset
and do the right things with it one of
the things i know when you guys move to
ue4 a lot of people you know
were worried about oh it's you know it's
breaking some of the pipeline of things
that people had done
previously and it sounds like with this
engine you're saying it's going to be
kind of a pretty seamless transition to
ue5 right that's important for you so i
have the the
forwards compatibility yeah absolutely
um
we want to support developers bringing
their games from ue4 to ue5
and in fact we will be doing that
ourselves with fortnite
so um we will be shipping fortnite on
next generation console on ue4
and then next year we will be bringing
fortnite to ue5 as well
so we'll be testing out that experience
of bringing a game along from
ue40 ue5 and making sure the transition
is
um is manu is manageable
wow yeah um you know fortnite obviously
such a phenomenon
as you mentioned earlier tim uh with you
know battle royales but
also i feel like you know fortnight has
turned into you know really kind of this
metaverse like platform where we're
seeing kind of different experiences
powered by unreal and i was wondering if
you guys could talk a bit about that
because i look at you know the travis
scott concert and i see that as an
amazing experience but it sort of was an
interactive music video in a way and
then you know you watch
the youtube video for his new song it's
actually you know just what was it
unreal
um how do you see these all those sort
of worlds of entertainment um
combining tim longer term and obviously
based on what kim was saying it's now
going to be even easier i guess for the
assets to move but
from an experience standpoint do you see
kind of a blending of games with more
traditional entertainment
powered by unreal yeah absolutely you
know all these worlds are colliding
right now in real time we're seeing
the sort of uh film production that's
being done on
the mandalorian and other projects all
around hollywood
film and television um you know
being able to move directly to games in
the future
right now we've brought marvel content
into fortnite and star wars content into
fortnite and each of those processes
started with
rebuilding their uh their you know movie
quality assets um for real time
you know using our tools but in the
future
this is going to be an exercise to build
every asset exactly once and then deploy
it everywhere
um and the future isn't just going to be
about unreal engine serving a bunch of
separate markets
we're helping architects visualize their
creations now
and that's awesome we're helping film
and television makers you know
virtually produce their work in real
time
uh you know with actors in front of an
actresses in front of
cameras and and big led screens instead
of
green screens and it's making the
production process much more efficient
real time and
higher quality um but you know in the
in the future all these assets are going
to come together and epic's not going to
just
play a role in supplying creation
software to all these different
industries
we're going to help everybody reach
consumers um with real-time 3d content
you know when general motors released
their corvette car configurator for the
2020 corvette
it was powered by unreal it was running
in the cloud and you could go there and
you could configure
your car right then but um you know that
was that was disconnected from the rest
of the gaming world
um the next step with all those types of
experiences
is to enable them to author that content
for all their internal work whether
you're building
designing a home for a customer as an
architect or
you're designing a car or you're
building a television series
we want the next generation of these
experiences to be
bringing all those assets directly to
gamers in a fun way
deploying them into fortnite and every
other unreal engine license use
games um being able to reach a vast
consumer audience that way
right it's like uh it's like the the
transition that the
world went through in the early days of
the internet um and then social media
you know for a while it was just
companies talking to customers
one-on-one and now it's
you have the ability to reach customers
directly to your facebook page or your
twitter
page you know your twitter account
anything like that but the next
generation of these experiences
is not just text and video it's real
time 3d it's a social experience for
players together
our player players are together with all
of their friends and experiencing
all these companies content together in
real time it's a world that's not going
to be powered by
advertisements that pop up and annoy you
it's a world that's going to be
powered by awesome content that these
companies make available
to power your entertainment experiences
and um
we're blazing this path to some extent
with fortnite but there will be a lot of
other games uh heading in this direction
loved and powered by unreal engine and
uh
i think this is the next step in the
entire digital content industry
not just gaming but the whole thing
i i couldn't agree more that's it's so
exciting to feel that games are going to
be at the center of this but as you said
i think you know this like
those shared experiences that you're
having in fortnight even you know a
concert experience there's
there's no gun play or combat involved
it's just a shared kind of experience
which is so compelling
um and he just said powered by unreal
and then when you think of as you said
those movie assets and
and all the other assets coming together
in a world um it's
it's really exciting one thing i wanted
to ask you about was the content
creation
um path because we've seen a lot
especially in fortnight with
you know creative mode and a lot of um
you know fans of fortnite starting to
build levels and obviously ue
um you guys i think have you know really
focused on kind of making it accessible
lowering the royalty rates for kind of
um you know upstart developers
can you maybe talk a bit about sort of
the you know your vision of kind of how
easy it is to you know build something
in unreal i mean are we going to get to
a level where it is sort of like a you
know
a photoshop where you can kind of just
jump in and build a game or what is that
buried entry going to go down in the
next generation
you know epic epic is working to address
the whole range of content development
scenarios
all the way from your aaa game developer
or
your feature film in hollywood i'm being
produced using
world-class photo real assets all the
way down to um
indie game experiences and uh you know
content creation for
the 100 million people who want to build
stuff but aren't
professional modelers and haven't had
training in that um
and a continuum of experiences spans
fortnite creative
which has been used by over 100 million
people all the way up to
unreal engine 4 and the unreal editor
which is an insanely powerful piece of
software that's actually pretty
complicated to learn
over time these these these tools and
technologies will be coming together in
some exciting ways and we're not we're
not ready to talk about all of it yet
but epic is really thinking about um and
putting a lot of effort into addressing
the entire continuum of content
development and content deployment
scenarios
um and yeah we feel that the
the state of the world is a little bit
broken right now if you look at the
app stores on smartphones you have
250 000 games each competing
for the top 10 charts where
virtually all of the sales occur and you
have a small number of winners and a
whole lot of losers in that way and it's
not a fair situation for game developers
and you have a lot of amazing games that
just get lost because they haven't been
discovered
um you know more and more we want to
enable
content creators to reach the audiences
within existing games
and you know this is this has been part
of the industry since the uh days of
quake and unreal tournament when
user mods became possible and we and id
software released our first tools
so the community could start building
their own stuff and now
it's reached a scale of hundreds of
millions of users if you look at what
fortnite is doing
and minecraft and roblox enabling user
content creation but um
i think i think right now you have two
separate worlds right you have the
professional
tools of unreal engine and unity and
then you have
the tools for the masses in fortnite
minecraft roblox and
they're really not connected anymore
they're not connected at all
and the next step is is to cross over um
and to enable uh all the content tools
to uh
reach all the customers and all the ways
that they play games um
and this is something we're thinking a
lot about um and uh
we'll be doing a lot of work on in the
in the coming years
it's awesome to hear um we've talked a
lot obviously about like graphics and
you know lighting and things that are
you know very powerful and visual that
grab you
um but i want to talk about the you know
the underlying architecture a little bit
and
things especially like online services
and i know that's something that you
know epic has focused on about kind of
connecting people you know even
cross-play but also
you know finding ways to kind of bring
communities together
um and i guess some of that's tied to
ue5 but also it's just a general
platform
approach but can you maybe share a bit
on kind of your vision on you know the
other aspects of unreal and epic and and
how that's going to sort of evolve over
the next few years too
oh sure you know today uh we're showing
on real engine 5 for the first time
but we're launching the epic online
services to all developers in the world
um across five platforms right now and
you can download the epic online
services sdk and use it right away
um what this is is the set of all the
online features that we built for
fortnite
um including cross-platform friends
uh that span seven platforms enable and
enable players to get together with all
of their friends everywhere
um you know despite the different
account systems and friend systems that
exist on each platform
um you know on the console platforms and
on steam um
and uh we're opening it up to all
developers for free
um and the the goal here is uh
is to help all developers work together
to to accomplish what we would
accomplish with fortnite um
and to build a a cross-platform
social ecosystem together with all of
the other developers in the industry
right um instead of uh instead of
players
being siloed into the you know into the
one platform they're playing on and it
we want them to be able to reach all of
their friends everywhere but also uh
build up friends across
multiple games um that's the really
interesting thing about the
epic account services that we're
launching um if you choose to use epic
accounts in your game
um then you can reach the entire
fortnight player base uh which is uh
over 350 million accounts um worldwide
and
more importantly it's 2.2 billion social
connections between players
uh you know when two players become
online friends and start playing
together
those uh those friend connections now
persist across games
um you know from all the different
publishers who choose to use these
services and so
you know it's it's the most open set of
services that have been launched today
um and it really helps to bridge the gap
um you know that suggests in all the
other
other platforms and until recently it
was really only epic ea
activision really big companies with a
huge set of
development resources that had the
capability of building that sort of
thing
but now this is open um it's approved by
all three of the console makers
for use on their on their platforms and
it's
ready for all game developers to adopt
and uh
so we're so really trying to to help the
industry get to a better place and we
think
you know the core of the game industry
are these you know 300 million hardcore
gamers across high-end pc and
you know and console um but there are
billions of gamers worldwide
and i think the next stage of the
industry's growth is going to come
from connecting these audiences you know
not with
low end casual games and winter
platforms and high-end games on another
set of platforms beginning all the
players to play together
and enabling all developers to release
their games on all platforms
as we did with fortnite yeah i think
that's
such an interesting idea that you know
these these gaming platforms almost
become you know
it's another social network now right
and i know you guys have house party
that's been very successful over the
past
a few months especially but it feels
like now you know you talk those numbers
with epic online services it starts to
feel like
this is you know a twitter or a snapchat
or an instagram and sort of this way to
kind of connect people
is that part of your longer term vision
is that people will will use sort of
these
game game services as as kind of a
gateway to connect with people and any
you know
games are a part of it but also just the
larger sort of social graph will be
kind of the gateway to it will be
through a game engine
well you know what we're building here
is the opposite of a wild garden right
we're enabling all publishers to use all
of their different account
systems and and connect using these
services
and we're working with all the different
console makers to
and other platforms and services to to
help interconnect them
the most interesting thing about this
and if you is
you know if you start playing fortnite
on playstation and then you want to play
the game on the ios device
on ios you can log in with your
playstation account um
and then you get all of your playstation
progress transferred over
if you start playing on pc then you
create an epic account then if you go to
xbox then you can log in with your epic
account on your xbox um and so
this isn't the world garden rather it's
an attempt to connect all the different
services you know so which are have
different degrees of openness um
and uh and i think that's that's really
going to be freeing for the industry
it's going to mean that
everybody can talk to everybody else and
there's no one company um controlling
the whole thing
rather it's a it rises as a result of
the cooperation between all the
different companies in the ecosystem
who finally realized that they can grow
better and build better businesses um if
instead of trying to lock players into
their platforms they enable their
players to connect with all of their
friends
across all platforms because uh you know
we have a lot of devices in our lives um
and everybody who has a an xbox or a
playstation
also has a an iphone or an android
device
um and uh and you know to to really
enable the next generation of industry
growth we've we've got to be able to
connect all of these users with all
these friends and set aside
kind of the old feuds defined previous
generations of the console business
so with everything you're describing i
think of you know a show like the
mandalorian which you know we all
watched and loved but all those assets
are there i mean there's nothing
prevents them now from building kind of
an interactive experience i guess around
that that they could power with
something like unreal and you know maybe
it's a game but maybe it's just sort of
this shared experience and it feels like
you know the visual fidelity now um that
these next gen consoles will bring i
mean
based on what you were saying kim and
nick it's like are things gonna look
just like
movie visual effects like what are the
things that i guess real time games
can't do still that we get to see in
some of these other shows
i you know i think i think we're getting
much much closer to this generation to
get to the point where
you're not going to be able to tell the
difference between the virtual world in
the real world there's still
you know physical phenomenon big massive
explosions and
you know um waves crashing on a beach i
think they're
they're still a little probably one
generation off before they're perfect
but we're getting closer and closer and
one of the coolest things that we've
seen um with the advent of
shows like the mandalorians starting to
use the engine is they're beginning to
understand that a game engine isn't just
around about rendering
pretty real-time pixels they're
understanding that game engines
especially unreal is built for building
these very immersive simulated worlds
so we're seeing people say they've got a
car chase in their tv show that they're
trying to make
then they'll actually drive cars with
steering wheels and
joy pads to to race against each other
and then film that after the fact
so it's starting to become very um
almost like very matrix work way in the
in the way that they're using simulation
for cinematic content creation and i
think that's just going to get more and
more
common and as they start to rock the
potential of what real time
um interactive entertainment is about i
think you're going to see traditional
storytellers
making the move into video games and i
think
and backwards and forwards i think
you're going to see this very very fuzzy
world
where uh where it's just entertainment
you're building an ip it can be a game
it can be a tv show
it can be all of these things and it's a
it's going to be a pretty exciting
decade
and i'm sure some people saw that uh you
know the showcase that you guys just
showed
the demo but everyone's like i want to
play that game but we should clarify
that's that's not a
game i don't think right it's just a
tech demo it's a tech demo
yes yes we feel it's that like the best
way to present especially
something that was built for the game
developer conference is to show
something within the context of
gameplay so uh and it also means you
know we wanted to improve some animation
systems in the engine
so it was much better to actually have a
world that you can walk through
play jump whatever um keeps it keeps it
real
or unreal in this case it's it's real
game play that's what we like to
like to see is that people can actually
play through that and again it's uh
it just blows me away when you see that
final sequence of the flight and that's
the kind of thing that i think we've all
been waiting for is to see that glimpse
of where games are
are going next so it's it's really
exciting to see uh how you guys keep
pushing the uh
you know pushing the technology uh to
the next level with ue5 and i know
um it's gonna be next year you say so
we'll see some
next-gen games this holiday shipping on
you know
brand you know ue uh 4.25 i think right
and then next year is when we'll see ue5
is that right
yeah that's right um we're planning on
having a
preview of ue5 available early next year
and then
shipping the full 5.0 uh later in the
year
yeah uh and i imagine uh you know
characters will also improve i know you
guys have done a lot of work there with
sort of you know character technology
we already talked about with nick you
know the idea of you know streaming more
into the environment you know no load
times as tim mentioned i mean these are
other things that i guess are gonna you
know
sort of impact the game experience but
are there other dimensions that you
think um
you know the next generation will sort
of evolve to with ue5 i mean i think the
character stuff
feels like to me another area where you
know we're not quite the same as
you know movies yet in terms of
character technology but i'm sure you
guys are pushing on that too
i i'm very confident oh sorry go ahead
tim
uh this is just the tip of the iceberg
here um
you know we've we've shown digital
humans technology in the past but uh you
know
epic and the three lateral team that
recently joined us are
are going to be pushing that to entirely
new levels i'm not just in graphics
finality but also
in productivity for content creators so
that
you know a developer without a huge
budget can build
digital humans that are world-class we
have a lot of investments going on that
you'll
hear about um over the coming months and
uh over the next year
um you know also at the core of this uh
this isn't a big open world demo but
open world technology
enabling worlds without balance is the
key
initiative that's uniting all of this
virtualized geometry is one part of it
um
global global elimination with lumen is
another part of it
but ultimately this comes together to
empower huge streaming seamless
environments and that
and that creates an entirely new
direction for games to go um and
remember this is not just a this is not
just a graphics engine right it's a full
simulation engine
um it aims to power every aspect of
simulating a realistic environment
including very detailed physics vehicles
and collision and destruction and
everything else i think
you'll see a qualitatively different
set of games for the new generation and
what we have here
and it's going to be very exciting
because we don't yet know exactly what
they're going to be
and how does uh you know you guys
mentioned fortnite moving to ue5 next
year like i mean how
how is this going to impact you know
fortnite do you think in terms of like
the game
you know with ue5 so you don't want to
spoil much but it's like just
technically sort of like is that going
to enable the game to evolve too
well it puts a vast amount of additional
new power in the hands of all the
creators who build fortnite um both
within epic
um and you know the 100 million or so
outside of epic
um yeah it's going to be very
interesting uh to see
to see where this enables uh the game to
go in the future i think
what we have now is a it's a very very
small fraction of uh
of what the game will be in the future
and uh you know
it's going to be very exciting to see
the fortnight team uh team evolve it
and have all this new power in their
hands when i see it
as you know it's a game but it it also
feels like a platform in a way that it's
enabling you know these other extreme
battle royale game but there's creative
and obviously we started to see you know
other experiences with
music artists and whatnot um around it
so it feels like it is this you know
this beachhead just sort of a bunch of
other content is that how you view it as
sort of this
uh you know sort of this people have
used the term you know
you know sort of metaverse but is that
sort of the longer term vision is that
fortnite can sort of grow to wherever
creators want to take it
yeah you know they define a platform as
a as an ecosystem in which uh
the uh most of the content is not
created by the
by the company that operates it right um
and uh
i think if you look at fortnite today
it's not that um but
anything's possible in the future i
think that's a
that's a very interesting direction for
the whole game business
every game developer is thinking about
this problem of uh
how to not limit their experience by the
10 or 100 or a thousand people on their
development team but how to
uncap the entire world's creativity to
enable
an entirely new generation of game
experiences to be developed in an
entirely new way
yeah well i think uh ue5 obviously shows
the high end of the aspiration for
everyone
to uh you know what they'll eventually
be able to maybe make and yeah that demo
is uh
absolutely stunning before we go i want
to ask you like that demo how long did
it take you guys to build how many
people worked on it can you give us a
sense of like you know
how that came to life uh well we started
thinking about it
straight out after gdc was when we
started thinking about it we knew
brian's
um brian's nanite technology was
beginning to come online
and but the bulk of the work i would say
the bulk of the work started from sort
of september
through to to march um and i think the
team
you know it probably peaked over this
but i think it was about two dozen
people that worked on the on the project
overall
and uh with a bit of help from our
friends at quicksole if it hadn't been
for the
quicksilver mega scan library we
couldn't be able to populate that world
yeah well that's i'm sure everyone looks
at that and says i want to play that
game and i know we're not necessarily
going to get it but uh it hopefully will
inspire a lot of creators around the
world about what will be possible
um you know with ue5 and also the next
generation system so
um yeah i i i feel real excited now
about what we're gonna get to see
um for the rest of the year for for all
these next-gen games and of course into
the future
um thanks as always for for joining me
guys uh
it's great to see the first look at ue5
and hear about where epic is going
and uh yeah the future looks quite
bright
thanks guys cool thank you thanks for
[Music]
bye
[Music]
b
graphics there were two
[Music]
so the next generation
it's great to see the first look at ue5
thanks guys
cool thank you
hello i'm brian kerris technical
director of graphics here at epic games
hello i'm brian karis technical director
of graphics
hello i'm brian kerris technical
[Music]
we couldn't be able to populate that
[Music]
this but i think it was about it's great
to see the first look at ue5
there were two key areas that stood out
the first
[Music]
fabletics is back with an all-new line
of leggings and bras fitted to make you
feel cute and confident
our latest leggings are available in
multiple styles colors and patterns and
come with convenient pockets to keep you
organized
pair them with one of our new bras which
come in a range of on-trend styles and
support levels
whether you're wearing fabletics to
brunch or yoga
you'll look and feel your best get your
first two pairs of leggings for just 24.
only at fabletics.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you